(beeping)
(uptempo electronic music)
- So as you know, life sciences are always
trying to make best use of light for many
different purposes.
For instance we use x-ray
beam for crystallography
and the infrared light for
vibrational spectroscopy.
But most biologists use visible light.
And chromophore is a structure unit
so that can absorb certain visible light,
and it is responsible for color
and in many cases it has
the Pi-conjugation system.
And single and double
bonds appear alternately
so that the Pi electrons
can be delocalized.
So, electrons oscillate
or sing on the chromophore
and that's quite important
for the interaction
with the visible light.
And my laboratory is engaged in
technological innovation in bio-imaging
and principally using
fluorescent proteins.
And I'd like to introduce to you,
so the most classical
the fluorescent protein
Aequorea GFP.
And long time ago, so in 1962
Osamu Shimomura discovered protein
and from the light-emitting
organ of the jellyfish.
And just 30 years later in '92 it's seen
then it was cloned by Doug Prasher.
And in '94, so the heterologous
expression with Aequorea GFP
was achieved by Martin
Chalfie at Columbia, okay.
And then this is the primary
structure of Aequorea GFP,
just 238 amino acid.
So there's no chromophore
that I defined a moment ago
in the peptide.
But from this three amino acid
get serine, tyrosine, glycine
so three reactions occur
spontaneously, okay.
And cyclization, dehydration
and oxidation reactions
to make the Pi-conjugation system.
So this is the GFP's chromophore
and which observes blue light, okay?
But this light doesn't say
anything about its fluorescence.
This is a crystal
structure, the Aequorea GFP
and the beta-barrel structure.
And the 11 stranded beta-barrel
with one alpha helix inside,
and the chromophore is
formed on the helix,
and that the barrel is very robust.
And the chromophore is packed inside
and it takes very rigid structure
so that explains why GFP's fluorescence
quantum yield is very high.
And the mutagen studies get
done by Dr. Roger Tsien,
so produced quite a few color variance
and the more useful and brighter.
And I stayed in Roger's
lab from '95 to '98
and I used CFP and the YFP
and as the donor and acceptor
for FRET so to create,
so the genetically encoded
indicator for calcium ion,
Cameleons as Mark mentioned kindly.
So now I'd like to discuss
why calcium imaging
is so interesting and appealing.
So there should be two major reasons.
First, calcium signaling
is very, so dynamic.
The concentration of free calcium ion
it changes so greatly so it should be fun.
To observe for instance
here calcium oscillations.
The second, so due to the endogenous
and the very abundant
calcium buffering systems
we can express a huge
amount of calcium probes
so without affecting intracellular calcium
dynamics very much, okay?
We can increase the signals,
signal-to-noise ratio.
Here we expressed a large
quantity of Cameleon
in excitatory neurons
with the forebrain mouse.
And we signed the skinless
head with excitation light
and to get these calcium readout.
And through this intact
skull and the video rate
and for more than 30 minutes.
So this readout reflect
spontaneous neuronal activities
and which are composed
of multiple oscillations
of different frequencies
and very symmetrical.
And the mouse was half awake
so when we gave visual stimulation
so we saw an evoked response in the path,
in the visual cortex.
Now back to, so this slide.
GFP is chromophore
and it has a phenol ring.
So it comes from tyrosine residue, okay?
Well, almost all of the
fluorescent proteins now available
so do have phenol rings in
their chromophores, okay?
And the exceptions, the CFP and the BFP,
so they have indole ring or imidazole ring
coming from tryptophan and the histidine.
But phenol ring containing
chromophore is most common.
And that there is an equilibrium
between protonated and ionized state
of the phenol hydroxyl group.
And that they then absorb
400 and 480 nanometer light.
And in many cases, so the
ionized form fluorescent, okay.
Therefore, GFP basically has
bimodal absorption spectrum.
And now a circular permutation.
And a long time ago just serendipitously
Geoff Baird and in Roger's lab found,
so this site 144, 145,
so the midpoint of the beta
strand number seven (mumbles),
so circular permutation.
So circular permuted GFP can synthesize
chromophore very well,
and now so the chromophore.
The equilibrium is quite
sensitive to a neighboring event
such as a calcium-dependent
protein-protein interaction.
So this is the operational
principle of GCaMP or pericam.
The very important point is that
so that here calcium-binding
changes absorption spectrum
not fluorescence quantum yield, okay.
As a kind of, a future perspective,
so the GCaMP should be well combined
with photo-acoustic imaging.
Now I have to say and
not only the jellyfish
but some of them are done
in animals or marine animals
so can produce quite similar
fluorescent proteins, okay?
And while we have cloned
many new fluorescent proteins
from those animals.
By using this, so these
green, red proteins,
we some time ago we
developed cell cycle probe.
And we used the Ubiquitin Oscillator.
Cell cycle-dependent proteolysis,
so to create the cell cycle probe
which labels individual
nuclei in genome phase red
and those in S, G2, M phases green.
That's FUCCI and the
green and red indicate,
so the go and stop.
The S phase entry, so
like a traffic signal
and when the FUCCI was
introduced into HeLa cells,
so derived from malignant tumor
we observed a cell cycle operation
in the other time at
the single cell level.
But when we did the same thing using
benign tumor-derived cell line
we saw very clear contact inhibition.
And upon reaching comfortable area
all of the cells became red
and then stopped so their proliferation.
And we introduced scratch
and so some of the cells
or that one in green
after some rate and time,
so they reenter the cell
cycle and to build a gap.
And we prepared FUCCI transgenic mice,
so this is a coronal section of an embryo
and in the brain, so neural stem cells
at the green nuclei line
in the ventricular zone
but post-mortem neurons
had only red nuclei
in the cortical (mumbles).
And the green and the red
signify cell proliferation
and the differentiation.
And during the embryogenesis with time,
so green to red ratio decreased,
so the earlier the more proliferation,
the later the more differentiation.
And after the burst so the
red signal became predominant
but even in adult tissue
so we can identify
very few green nuclei
and the cells with the green nuclei
corresponded to tissue stem
cells like a neural stem cells
found in the dentate gyrus, okay.
And when we used zebrafish
embryo very transparently
so we can obtain cell cycle
profile in four dimensions.
So this is a segmentation period of embryo
and a side view on head and tail,
and again with time green
to red ratio decreased
but some other organs
like retina and the brain,
so very green.
And in top view in addition to two eyes,
so we saw a notochord.
So differentiating notochord
and in notochord we discovered,
so the cell cycle
transitions moved, traveled
from head to tail like this.
So G1, this transition moved towards here.
And we think, so the cell cycle regulation
in the notochord is
linked to somite genesis
which is also characterized
by head to tail
progression of differentiation.
But anyhow, it's quite very amazing
that we can visualize that
the middle of the body
from outside so that's just because,
so the fish embryo's a bit transparent.
And by contrast, mouse embryos,
well, mammary animals where
including us are turbid.
Yes, visible light
scatters very much inside
so our body so like now mentioned, okay?
Now, tissue clear identification
and long time ago we discover that
the membrane for Western Blotting analysis
it became transparent when
soaked in four molar urea.
And we knew that, so the GFP beta-barrel,
it's a brave and tough, so rigid
and tolerant of high
concentration of urea.
We started, so the clearing
and devolution in 2011,
so with our paper on ScaleA2
which is the first and urea-based
aqueous solution for tissue
clear identification.
And then it was followed by many explosion
of many new techniques,
and also two years ago we
reported some modification
ScaleS, ScaleS that contains
sorbitol in addition to urea
and we verify that ScaleS can preserve
the fluorescent signal
and also outer structures,
so subset of outer
structures like a synapse.
I think researchers should be aware
of the critical trade-off
between effective clearing
and the tissue signal preservation.
And also we invented AbScale method
so which enables three-dimensional
immunohistochemistry.
And some time ago the Saito group at BSI
generated a single APP
knock-in mouse models
of Alzheimer disease.
And we applied AbScale method,
so to the brain of aged APP knock-in mice.
And to visualize A beta-plaques we used
Alexa488 labeled and antibody.
And there was a brain got
prepared from a nine-month old
and APP knock-in mouse and very sparse.
But in 18-month old, so we saw,
we observed so many
immuno-labeled A beta-plaques
and yes, even the experiment,
we transcardially perfused
the entire vasculature
with Texas Red-lectin
to label blood vessels
with red fluorescence
and then we immune-stained
the A beta-plaques with green
and to obtain this, so the 3D perspective.
Very comprehensive perspective of how
A beta-plaques interferes
with blood vessels.
Then we took interest
in a special association
of A beta-plaques with microglial cells.
And we applied so the dual color AbScale
so to a brain slice prepared
from APP knock-in mouse.
And we analyzed the interaction
between these two object
by light sheet microscopy observation.
And we measured the distance
from each microglia center
to the nearest plaque age in the 3D space.
Those measurements should
provide the information about
stability of plaque
neuritis, inflammatory state.
For instance, so two neighboring
plaques with similar size
but different association
with microglial cells,
very direct to contact
versus very isolated.
We think they suggest acute
neuritic state versus obsolete.
And in a similar way we 3D imaged plaque
microglia association in
post-mortem brain samples
of AD patient of more than 50 years old.
And in these three brain
samples we observed,
detected very clear cored
plaques, green ones.
And the cored plaques without
and with microglia association.
But in the remaining
six of the brain samples
we didn't see any cored plaques.
So then we became interested
in diffused plaques.
So diffused plaques are
basically undetectable,
not detectable in the
two-dimensional image.
But our new software can re-slice,
so the 3D reconstruction systemically
and with different sizes,
different thickness, okay?
And that helped us to identify
diffused plaques of different sizes.
And the diffused plaques are usually
assumed to be very
primitive and very isolated
from any inflammatory cells,
but we found, so most of
them can show the sign of
neuritis with considerable
association with microglial cells.
Clinically, diffused plaques are ambiguous
but they're potentially
very, very important, okay?
And Scale plus FUCCI we
studied vascular niche
for neural stem cells
in the dentate gyrus.
And that we were able...
So neural stem cells or
proliferative neural stem cells
we used FUCCI S, G2, M phase marker
and the blood vessels
were labeled with red.
And the green nuclei,
so the neural stem cells
were indeed localized
inside the dentate gyrus
not outside of it.
And we again performed
distance measurement
in a three-dimensional space.
We measured distance
from each green nucleus,
so to the nearest blood vessel, okay?
And then we came to a conclusion,
so the neural stem cells are more closely
associated with blood
vessels than matured neurons.
And Rusty has been saying about
hippocampal neurogenesis is operated by
exposure to enriched environment
and we performed the
comparative experiment,
comparative experiment and
large-scale 3D reconstruction.
And our data showed the
enriched environment increased
so the number or density
of neural stem cells
but did not change so their
association with blood vessels.
This a comprehensive data I think, I hope.
All right, so this slide is an interplay
between light and life.
Well I remember that Roger Tsien,
Roger used to remind us
nature is very kind to us,
to researchers
and that nature still
remains the best source
of bio-imaging tools, okay?
And this is my last slide
and only a scientist
with a respect for nature
would have been permitted to surpass it
in English, Japanese and Chinese.
And thank you very much for attention.
(audience applauding)
(uptempo electronic music)